tout semblait étonnamment calme quand
nous sommes entrés à aux rives pourtant
deux jours en jouant la guerre se
rapproche
sur la place centrale quelques fermiers
ont même installé leurs étals ce matin
les jours de marché avant dit oleg
beaumont la place était pleine de monde
les gens venaient de partout autour
aujourd'hui chacun se dépêchent de faire
quelques courses
je peux seulement prier nous y tetyana
je ne souhaite qu'une chose dit elle
c'est la paix mais
quelques instants plus tard
[Musique]
la sirène d' alerte
c'est le temps de rentrer pas de panique
juste de la résignation
tamara qui espéraient faire quelques
sous ou aujourd'hui ramassis lentement
ses produits d'accord je ne renie à
trévoux boulette c'est chaque jour la
même chose nous dit elle un peu excédé
des sirènes des bombes on ne peut pas
dormir c'est terrifiant
nous nous dirigeons vers les quartiers
plus près de la ligne de front
à l'aube c'est un jardin d'enfants qui a
été touché les russes y ont largué une
bombe heureusement l'endroit était vide
il n'y a pas eu de victime
pendant que nous sommes là les tirs se
rapproche les rues sont pratiquement
déserte une bonne partie de la
population a déjà quitté la ville les
femmes et les enfants surtout il reste
les hommes qui doivent se battre et
beaucoup de personnes âgées qui n'ont
pas les moyens de s'en aller qui se
retrouvent dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles
les échanges sont incessants les russes
viennent de frapper cet entrepôt de
semences le blé il devait servir à
nourrir la population locale
la voie ferrée a été endommagé et le
voisinage brûle cela fait des jours que
les combats se poursuivent ainsi
les ukrainiens résiste en face d'eux les
troupes russes seraient importantes elle
occupe déjà trois villages autour et
theory rives tomber moscou pourrait
élargir le territoire déjà contrôlée par
les séparatistes pro-russes du donbass
mais la mairesse adjointe nous assure
sans le moindre doute que cela
n'arrivera pas à les méchins et menaces
web
ou deux nous sommes plus forts on est
chez nous dit elle et nous sommes
ukrainien on l'était on l'est on va le
rester
de retour plus près du front dans les
immeubles abandonnés
seules quelques personnes âgées
s'aventurent à l'extérieur
la plupart dépendent de l'aide
humanitaire pour survivre zone astro ils
ne sont plus que trois femmes dans ce
bâtiment dit valentino elle s'occupe de
sa mère de 87 ans il ne veut pas s'en
aller donc gratuite je vous promets
moore qui peut nous aider à arrêter
cette guerre dit-elle aidez nous j'ai
mes enfants mes petits enfants et je ne
peux pas les voir c'est trop dangereux
comme tous ceux qui restent valentina se
prépare aux prochains bombardements mais
personne ici ne comprend pourquoi la
russie s'acharne sur eux il menait une
vie si tranquille avant
céline galipeau radio canada aux rives